my name is Jake Morrison and the visual
effects supervisor for Thor Ragnarok
challenge on this Thor and the stuff
that we did from scratch was we knew
that we had to rebuild our Hulk he has
to talk which is cool it became clear
that not only did he have to talk here
to tell jokes just a couple of hotheaded
fools
yes a hawk like fire door like water we
really tried to bring a lot more Mark
Ruffalo to the character The Hulk is
like a two-ton beast so you actually
kind of want to slow marks gate down a
little bit we took these heavy hands and
heavy feet and actually strapped them to
his ankles and to his wrists so every
time you did a gesture it was a little
bit slower a little bit more measured we
also have this incredible system that we
built
so whatever Marc was doing in the room
the actual camera operator could look
through the eyepiece and see the eight
foot six Hulk superimposed over the
scene so Tiger would have the the
freedom to improv its shot very much
like an indie what he asked us from the
very beginning was to try and make the
techniques and the technology
transparent so he could really just play
and throw lines the actors we know each
other he's a friend from work from the
very beginning we knew that there were
scenes that we were going to be doing an
IMAX but we wanted to make sure that we
could do any of them I think the larger
VFX scenes translate perfectly we were
told to make the biggest arena that had
ever been made on any planet ever which
we did so we actually finished the
entire movie to IMAX height then it
becomes an aesthetic moment isn't what's
the moment where you want to bring the
spectacle so you're actually the
audience when they see the IMAX piece
we'll see more the final battle looks
absolutely epic in IMAX
this
[Music]